[Musique]
renault accélère dans l'électrique avec
10 nouveaux modèles d'ici 2025 dont la
mégane électrique des buts 2022 bonjour
le caddie mais au bonjour david ça va
installer au mercy est là directeur
général donc évidemment de renault la
mégane électrique je n'ai pas dit un qui
est construite en france
vous misé gros sur ce lancement ouais
c'est une des ses le segment le plus
important en europe
donc de catégorie moyenne pour nous
c'est un grand projet alliance donc avec
une plateforme qui avait globalement
partagé avec nissan et un jour peut-être
avec mitsubishi donc on mise en fait la
crédibilité de renault comme pionnier
dans l'électrique rentrer dans le coeur
du marché européen en faisant le choix
de produire tout j'insiste toutes vos
voitures électriques même sur le sol
français même les petits modèles même
les modèles d'entrée de gamme pourquoi
vous prenez ce pari industriel est ce
que c'est un pari qui est risqué ou pas
pour renault je pense que les risques et
parce que c'est pas évident de faire des
choix de ce type
mais je comprends la valeur de remettre
au nom au centre
de la conversation dans le pays où on
est mais donc au 90e + française
donc il fallait se voit là se prendre ce
risque et se donner ce défi mais je
pense qu'on va le gagner comment faire
pour être aussi compétitif que ses
rivaux qui ne produisent pas en france
et qui ont pour le coup parfois dans
certains pays des mains d'oeuvres qui
sont moins chers ben il ya il faut
travailler surtout sur toute la chaîne
anglo mais ça dépend du choix que
technique que tu fais sur la voiture de
comment tu fais l'ingénieur de ça c'est
son tour et de fournisseurs qui sont à
côté de ton usine la décision qu'on a
prise de
faire venir un partenaire pour localiser
les in de batterie juste à côté
de l'usiné de doué c'est le travail
qu'on a fait au niveau de relation avec
les parties prenantes pour définir un
nouveau contrat qui nous permettra
d'être plus compétitive parce qu'en 15
ans le cadet méo la production de
voitures sur le sol français vous le
savez été divisé par deux est ce que la
voiture électrique c'est une forme d'
opportunité pour la france d'inverser
cette tendance moi je suis un j'en suis
totalement convaincu dans la partie
france
du plan renault lution que peut être
vous avez entendu parler de ça
c'est clair que on comprend très bien
que la le fait de transformer toute la
filière autour de la possibilité de
construire des voitures électriques ça
ça va donner de la valeur ça va créer
surtout de la valeur ajoutée nous on
croit on a fait des études dont on croit
que horizon 2030 si toute la filière se
transforme en prenant cette opportunité
il y a à la clé 70 80 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires qu'on peut créer
dans ce pays c'est donc une opportunité
en même temps c'est aussi une menace
parce que 65 mille emplois sont menacés
dans le secteur d'ici 2030 c'est ce que
dit luc chatel qui est à la tête de
plateformes automobiles oui on sait très
bien parce qu'on se parle beaucoup avec
lui qu'on est les enjeux il ya
évidemment un défi de transformation de
beaucoup d'entreprises y en a et partis
qui sont très bien positionnés pour le
futur et d'autres études qui devront se
transformer et d'autres encore qui
malheureusement vont disparaître parce
que le business lié au thermique ne soit
plus là mais je vous donne la bonne
nouvelle c'est que d'un côté on voit à
60 certains disent 50 dos tandis 65 ou
sont 1000 mhz et deux emplois qu'on
pourrait perdre mais si on fait le
travail de transformation à tous les
niveaux je pense qu'on a la clé quelque
chose comme 400 500 mille emplois sur le
mend celle de la valeur de l'automobile
donc il faut plutôt se projeter à créer
et se retrousser les manches pour créer
ces opportunistes qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes et menaçant la vie avec cet
objectif de 2 millions de voitures
électriques et d'ailleurs et hybride
produite en france est l'objectif fixé
par le président de la république c'est
très ambitieux c'est jouable et si oui à
quelles conditions moi je pense que
c'est jouable je pense aussi que renault
est peut-être dans les conditions à cet
horizon-là de aller au dessus des 500
milles peut-être six cent mille petits
37 cents mille voitures électriques
produits en france c'est un peu simple
le plan donc on va faire la nôtre partie
du job là dedans dit job et on va créer
des emplois et on va aussi créer des
emplois indirects dans une partie de ses
cinq cent mille évoqué avant produire en
france et ce que luca di meo c'est un
pic de vendre des voitures un prix plus
élevé
le prix du marché n'est pas défini et
nécessairement par les coulées défini
par le marché les voitures électriques
vont être plus cher ça il faut c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut à l'achat il
faut l'accepter parce que un peu qu'on
ait une moto propulseur électrique ça
coûte trois ou quatre fois le prix d'un
moteur thermique avec une boîte extra
classique évidemment les voitures
électriques ça va être payée par les
gens qui ont du pouvoir d'achat au début
au moins le temps que la technologie
rendront dans les volumes ans puissent
baisser les coûts sur le moteur
thermique on y travaille depuis 130 ans
sur les batteries depuis 20 20 donc il
faut accepter qu au début comme
n'importe quel produit ça peut être un
téléphone ça peut être un ordinateur etc
ça au début si elle vole technologiques
ce qui n'inclut plus cher puis sa baisse
qu'est ce qu'on dit aux français qui
nous regardent qui ne veulent pas en
tout cas pas encore passé à l'électrique
parce que saku 10000 15000 euros plus
cher qu'une voiture essence parce que
l'autonomie et cette question qui
jugeait pour certains en tout cas trop
faible parce qu'il ya cette borne de
recharge on en parlait juste avant
qu'est ce qu'on leur dit ah ces français
soit en un petit peu il faut je pense
qu'il faut il faut commencer il faut
commencer à acheter des voitures éthique
d'ailleurs on est déjà un pourcentage
double chiffre dans les ventes de
renault ça commence à ces 10 % c'est sa
tête c'est un vrai plus 10% après ça
dépend des mois mais c'est déjà
je veux dire un mix important dans nos
ventes je crois que l'expérience avec
une voiture électrique et l'exceptionnel
d'un point de vue plaisir de conduite
utilisation du produit parce que les
voitures sont silencieuses et accélère
il ya une architecture qui permet d
habitacle qui sont très spacieux et
c'est là donc c'est vraiment sympa
franchement c'est clair que au début ça
coûte cher il ya plein de façons je
voulais de de diluer ce prix avec des
financements avec des suggestions du
leasing et c'est là en utilisation sûre
d'être moins cher et ça il faut faire le
calcul vous dire combien de kilomètres
en bas ça dépend de combien de
kilomètres du fait mais anglo en gros tu
dépenses moins de 3 euros en recherche
dans la voiture of à 100 km alors qu'une
voiture thermique tu dépenses site 7 ou
8 euros c'est ça la proportion donc là
la sensation que tu as et que en
utilisation c'est moins il ya moins
d'entretien dans les voitures et rick
donc ça a certainement ses désavantages
et après je voue aujourd'hui aussi on
parle tout le temps voix de diminuer
l'impact des transports sur
l'environnement il faut que chacun fasse
sa part est en train d'investir des
milliards dans la voiture et rick
justement pour baisser la moyenne des
missions de notre flotte il faut que de
l'autre côté le marché les clients et
ils participent à cette révolution
comment fait baisser le prix d'une
voiture électrique quand on sait que la
batterie c'est 40 % du coût de la
voiture la batterie c'est le nerf de la
guerre en faisant baisser les cours de
batterie est temps que pour vous d'être
là parce qu'aujourd'hui les batteries
pardon le guen d'azir les les batteries
et viennent d'asie mais c'est pas
seulement la question je veux dire que
normalement on asie ils font des
produits très compétitive en course
et a plutôt complexe mais en gros il
faut imaginer qu'une batterie en termes
de performances
et donc de coûts va baisser entre 7 et
10% chaque année donc pour dean pour
réduire 50% le prix d'une d'une batterie
faudra dix ans ok donc c'est
technologique n'est pas complètement
disruptif comme disent les anglais mais
il ya moyen vraiment et on l'a vu avec
la batterie par exemple de la zoé dans
les derniers dix ans on a réduit de 50%
le coup et ça va continuer comme ça on a
aussi besoin des volumes on a besoin de
mettre les usines à côté de nos usines
par ses batteries électriques elles
seront produites en france ici un tarif
compétitif par rapport à ce qui se fait
en asie l'enjeu il est solide ce combat
cette bataille n'est pas perdue pour les
européens moi je pense que sur cette
technologie mais je pense que
certainement l'asie a un avantage on
peut partir du de laval en fait quand tu
as continué une usine à côté de toutes
origines assemblage déjà il ya un
avantage en termes de coûts losique
logistique c'est claire que le volume va
va faire une partie de la de la baisse
des coûts il ya un enjeu aussi important
surtout dans le futur c'est que
suffisant on rentre dans une dans un
système où il y aura des taxes carbone
de taxe de ce type la frontière
évidemment à la frontière par notamment
en france on est capable entre le
renouvelables et le nucléaire on est
capable de vraiment
produire des batteries avec des coûts
d'énergie qui sont assez compétitive onc
un coup en co2 qui va être moindre donc
ça c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
j'ai poussé pour lancer deux projets en
france deux usines de batteries 1 c'est
celui qu'on fait au nord et un autre
qu'on fait avec une start up française
qui s'appelle vercors sur laquelle on
est en train de décider la localisation
de la musique deuxième usine donc ça
c'est un enjeu majeur le thème de
l'impact dans la production après il
faut savoir que pour faire une batterie
il faut des cathodes le 90% de la
production de cathodes il est fait on
asie pour faire des cadeaux il faut des
matières premières donc donc il a trick
ne sera jamais 100% française évidemment
mais elle sera assemblée en france mais
sera et des compos mais justement je
pense que l'enjeu se sera de construire
avec d'autres industries tout là toute
la filière du raffinage débattent des
matériaux il est fait à 80% en chine
donc il faudra construire des capacités
de raffinage du cobalt du nickel du
lithium donc c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que simplement mettre une une
usine de batteries parce que le 50% de
la valeur on fêtait en amont de sa donc
une baisse des batteries électriques de
50% à horizon 10 ans oui c'est faisable
oui et donc la parité entre le prix une
voiture électrique et thermique cette
fête pour quand mais nous on pense que
quand on fait nos calculs on pense que
ça peut être dans quatre cinq ans parce
que dans le nôtre dans le maine comme
dans la période le coût des moteurs
thermiques va augmenter avec
l'électrification libéralisation toutes
les normes de dépollution donc on y aura
un croisement qui se fera dans 4 5 en
termes de coût mais il faut être clair
ça va se faire par le haut c'est à dire
les voitures thermiques ont coûté plus
cher et les voitures et et égaux en
coûtait moins cher mais ce sera plus
cher qu'aujourd'hui et la voiture
électrique low cost c'est aussi une
solution pour ceux qui veulent se lancer
nous on aura déjà dans le marché sont on
a introduit cette année à la datcha
spring ça vaut 15000 euros c'est une
voiture qui a du succès c'est une
voiture assez essentielle dans le style
de des chats on voit bien que ça marche
je pense que il ce n'est pas qu'une
question de prix d'entrée je pense qu'il
faut qu'on fasse des produits comme on
sait dans le cas de la mégane qui sont
capables voilà deux de satisfaire
beaucoup de besoins qui ont du conte
unités megan électrique pour début 2011
22 produite en france les voitures
électriques en chine ont en fait on
finit là dessus 100% électrique c'est
10% à 10 ans pour cent des ventes vous
vous êtes fixé un objectif je parle
horizon 5 ans de se dire ça sera à 30%
des dévoués et on pense que on pense
qu'on devrait être à 25% une voiture sur
quatre ans 25 et on sera peut-être la
moitié
en totale au total total en 30 mai en un
temps de travail le marché ou en agent
sera plutôt en avance qu'on cherchait
donc à l'horizon 2030 peut donc
peut-être on sera complètement
électrique comme marc renoux voilà merci
d'arrêter avec new look à des mélodies
qu'en général de renault merci à vous
[Musique]